[Music]
happy for happy birthday America as we
gear up to celebrate this year we're
taking a look back at nine times we
totally had FOMO from our favorite stars
Independence Day celebrations Heidi Klum
celebrated the nation's birthday by
hitting the beach but like literally
Sofia Vergara had us drooling over her
red white and blue themed treats let's
just say the preparation for that sweet
feast required Sophia to do some serious
heavy lifting
Paris Hilton may have spent Independence
Day in Ibiza but there's no doubt she
was the brightest star of all God kaley
cuoco and her boyfriend Carl cook gave
us some serious fashion MV with their
Uncle Sam themed attire Lena Gomez
jumped into party mode proving she's the
hostess with the mostess is there
anything better than watching fireworks
from the McDonald's drive-through Mindy
Kaling gave this sparkling moment a
perfect 100 Taylor Swift never
disappoints when it comes to her fourth
of July parties and last year was no
exception
[Music]
joined by Blake Lively gigi hadid and
Ruby Rose Jay Taylor besties
totally embodied Stars and Stripes
[Music]
Chrissy Teigen through a patriotic
soiree fit for a goddess in the Hamptons
she and hubby John Legend may not be
able to swim but that didn't stop them
from lounging around on floaties can we
say hashtag dreamy but it's this shot of
Justin Timberlake and Jessica Biel's
little guy waving a flag that will
completely melt your heart
[Music]
Oh